president biden tells americans in
afghanistan they're supposed to rely on
the mercy of the taliban america's
enemies accelerate their aggressive
behavior and the hard left signals that
conservatives are the real taliban i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protect it at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first your reminder the fact
is that your internet services they are
not private going online without
expressvpn it's like leaving your kids
with the nearest stranger while you are
using the restroom you would never do
that so why would you go online without
express vpn every time you connect to an
unencrypted network in cafes hotels
airports etc your online data is not
secured any hacker on the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data that includes like
passwords and your financial details etc
it doesn't take much technical knowledge
to hack somebody just some cheap
hardware is needed a smart 12 year old
could probably do it somebody smarter
than the president of the united states
your data is valuable hackers can make
up to one thousand dollars per person
selling personal information on the dark
web expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet hackers cannot steal your
sensitive data it's super secure it
would take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressive vpn's encryption systems
it's easy to use you can fire up the app
and click one button to get protected
and it works on all your devices phones
laptops tablets and more so you can stay
secure on the go again you don't want to
leave your internet activity unprotected
because why would you secure your online
data today visit expressvpn.com ben
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
you get an extra three months for free
it's expressivevpn.com
ben alrighty so disaster continues to
roll out in afghanistan the taliban are
doing what they do best namely torturing
and murdering people
so video has now emerged of the taliban
torturing translators for example and
people who had translated on behalf of
the american military who was there
and then yesterday apparently there were
people who were carrying afghanistan's
old flag you know the non-taliban flag
that was flying over kabul until just a
couple of days ago and the taliban did
what they do best they just opened fire
into the crowd according to all arabia
members of the extremist group opened
fire on the crowd at least two people
that at least 10 people injured here is
some of the video
you can see people begging to leave i
mean this is
it's it's
for for our empathetic president to just
walk away from all of this knowing that
he facilitated all of this without any
plan for transition is really despicable
it's quite despicable
but as we'll see
president biden when it comes to this
sort of stuff is pretty despicable in
general here's some video of afghan
girls begging in the american military
to take them with them because they know
what's going to happen which is
effectually sex slavery for everybody
under a particular agency
[Music]
i remember when people say well you know
they're just going back to the lifestyle
that they chose they're just going back
to what they knew before many of these
girls have never known this lifestyle
the united states invaded afghanistan in
2001 it is now 2021 girls who are 18 19
20 years old have never lived under the
taliban they do not remember what it is
like to live under the taliban if you're
under 25 years old in afghanistan this
means you have never really experienced
a taliban rule in a way that you can
remember
because again the united states took
over the country in 2001 and then handed
it over to our afghan allies so the the
bizarre idea that this was approved by
the afghan population generally speaking
particularly in the major cities that
were controlled by the united states
like like
kabul is quite crazy it's quite crazy
and you can see the fallout from this
here for example is the first afghan air
force pilot who is female her name is
rahmani pleading for president biden to
hear her to save the families of people
who worked with the united states who
are going to get stuck there all these
women by the way are going to get raped
all these women are going to get sold
into sex slavery if you're a single
woman you will by 13 14 years old have
been
married off to somebody if not raped or
you will be married and then raped that
is the way things worked under the
taliban from 1996 to 2001 when they ran
the place and that has come back in
spades
here is this afghan female pilot talking
about it
as an afghan woman
i would like for president biden to hear
me the government that please save the
families
that they need you the woman the little
girls that they always looking up and to
the united states the great army that
united states uh brought to afghanistan
and also please save my family
well the good news is that the media are
apparently dedicated to the proposition
at least to a certain extent that the
taliban might be okay you're starting to
see this theme running through the media
not everybody in the media i think there
are some people in the media who are on
the left and are surprisingly actually
doing some honest media coverage
i think that you've seen this from for
example richard engel over at nbc news i
think you've seen this from jake tapper
over at cnn there are some members of
the media who are still doing some
honest media coverage of this but i
think the tendency over the coming days
is going to be to suggest that the
taliban have in some way moderated in
the same way that the media went along
with the narrative that the iranian
regime had moderated and therefore it
was time for the united states to make
concessions to the milocracy i think
you're going to get that from the
taliban as well with regards to the
media the taliban know how to play this
so the taliban spokesperson yesterday
for example said yeah you know women do
have rights you know we're going to
acknowledge women's rights now and then
they add the little phrase that makes
all of that mood that comply with sharia
if you say that women have rights that
comply with sharia that means women
don't have rights okay sharia law in the
taliban's interpretation of islamic
fundamentalist law means women do not
have rights but here they are saying
what they think the west wants to hear
the question
what kind of guarantees can you provide
for
ensuring women's rights
as i said as a mission
the women are going to be very active in
the society
but within the frameworks of islam
uh within the frameworks of islam under
sharia
by the way this is why women young girls
are already being sent home from school
like already
that is the wonderful zabihullah mujahid
i'm sure we'll hear more from the
spokesperson for the 8th century
barbarian taliban malala yousafzai who
you'll recall was hailed the world over
for her willingness to fight for women's
education in afghanistan she now writes
in the new york times in the last two
decades millions of afghan women and
girls received an education now the
future they promised is dangerously
close to slipping away the taliban who
until losing power 20 years ago barred
nearly all girls and women from
attending school and doled out harsh
punishment to those who defied them are
back in control like many women i fear
for my afghan sisters
she says afghan girls and young women
are once again where i have been in
despair over the thought they might
never be allowed to see a classroom or
hold a book again some members of the
taliban say they will not deny women and
girls education or the right to work but
given the taliban's history afghan's
women's fears are real already we are
hearing reports of female students being
turned away from their universities
female workers from their offices none
of this is new for the people of
afghanistan
she says that she's going to try and
funnel money in there but uh good luck
to her good luck to her
because the taliban is not going to
allow any of this and everybody knows
that this is the case at this point
the desperation of people attempting to
leave is just overwhelming
i mean there was a picture that was
making the rounds yesterday that is
shocking right this is a picture of a
man's legs
from underneath the wheel well
of a plane this would be an american jet
hey they're above the cloud line so they
are thousands of feet high this person
grabbed onto the wheel well of a plane
in an attempt to escape and we already
know according to politico that one man
his body was found mangled in the wheel
well of an american c-17
hey you know what kind of desperation it
takes in order to do that some pretty
significant desperation by the way the
taliban has been shooting at afghans
near the airport so anybody who is
attempting to escape the taliban
shooting
joe biden decided it'd be a good idea to
hand the country back over to these
people they said this would be a great
idea
all it took was maintaining a bare bones
troop presence 2 500 troops in a support
capacity fixing airplanes and he decided
not worth it let's leave these
barbarians in charge of a country of 38
million people probably that'll provide
no threat to the united states in terms
of an uptick in uh in terror threat
and by the way subjecting 38 million
people to the predations of some of the
worst people on planet earth uh there
was a time by the way when joe biden who
is now ardently against nation building
he said there was an alternative to
nation building since 2003.
in some parts of the administration
nation building is still a dirty phrase
but the alternative to nation building
is chaos
a chaos that churns out bloodthirsty
warlords drug traffickers and terrorists
and we have we've seen it happen in
afghanistan before
and i am quite frankful fearful it may
happen again
ooh just um yeah well he's changed his
tune somewhat by 2010 by the way
this is what's so amazing when you look
to your politicians for empathy you are
looking in the wrong place you're
looking in the wrong place it is stupid
to look to your politicians for empathy
i first of all i don't think the
politicians should operate on the basis
of empathy i think they should operate
on the basis of rational calculation i
don't think joe biden does either i
don't think he operates on the basis of
empathy or on the basis of rational
calculation but just to remind you for
all those people who believe that joe
biden is a kindly old grandfather figure
here's what joe biden had to say in 2010
about pulling out of afghanistan so
richard holbrook had a diary richard
holbrook was the special envoy from the
obama administration to afghanistan and
pakistan and holbrook
asked biden about america's obligation
to maintain presence in afghanistan to
protect vulnerable civilians and here is
what biden responded
f that we don't have to worry about that
we did it in vietnam nixon and kissinger
got away with it
f that well
man is true to his word f that and f
those people by the way again our
weaponry is now in the hands of these
barbarians
according to jake sullivan the national
security advisor who did just a
cataclysmically bad performance
yesterday in front of the press i mean
this is just a catastrophe in terms of
public relations the national security
adviser jake sullivan rhodes scholar
genius all the way around obama hold
over
he says oh yeah by the way billions of
dollars of our weaponry is now in the
hands of the taliban
what happens to the billions of dollars
worth of weaponry that the us gave
afghanistan does the us have a plan for
that or does it remain in the taliban
we don't have a complete picture
obviously of where every article
uh of defense materials has gone but
certainly a fair amount of it has fallen
into the hands of the taliban and uh
obviously
we don't
have a sense that they are going to
readily hand it over to us at the
airport
we don't have a sense they're going to
of course they're not going to hand it
over give them billions of dollars in
sophisticated weaponry
of course
no they're gonna come they're gonna
they're gonna show up with their m wraps
and be like you know what guys we know
that you're leaving and just a parting
gift we decided to give you back just
billions of dollars in military hardware
including sophisticated drone technology
by the way we are busily trying to scrub
any biometric
materials that we have in afghanistan
because the taliban are going through
all of that stuff and they are finding
everybody who worked with us and then
they are murdering those people
okay so jake sullivan was also asked why
biden had ignored intelligence reports
suggesting that precisely this was going
to happen and this is the amazing thing
none of this was unforeseeable
unforeseeable
it was all precisely foreseeable
i mean many of us have been predicting
this for years that if the united states
pulled out there'd be absolute chaos in
afghanistan for god's sake i wrote a
novel in like 2016 or 2015 talking about
what would happen if the united states
pulled out of afghanistan precipitously
and how the embassy would fall it didn't
take a genius to figure this stuff out
this is the most obvious thing in the
world but many in the intelligence
community were saying yeah this is going
to collapse really really fast jake
sullivan was asked so why did you ignore
all of that
numerous officials have told abc that
there were key intelligence assessments
warning the taliban could overwhelm the
country and take the capital within
weeks did the white house disregard that
intelligence and
push ahead
i'm not actually familiar with the
intelligence assessment you're
describing
but i also don't want to get into
specific intelligence products and one
thing i will not do from this podium or
anywhere else
is
talk about
what a different component of the
interagency did or didn't do
yeah i mean he's committed to the
classification process obviously and
that's why he's not answering the
question not because the biden
administration completely and thoroughly
blew this but because he has to make
sure that classified information doesn't
spill into the public you mean
classified information about what we
knew about the collapse of the afghan
security that class like because we can
all see it in real time happening like
now i don't need a classified report
from six months ago to tell me what was
going to happen i can see it happening
like in the moment right now my favorite
here is jake sullivan saying oh yeah no
no we definitely take responsibility but
by the way everyone else is responsible
i take responsibility for this but
really it's on you it's really on sort
of everyone isn't it
i mean like sure uh a man comes home and
he says to his wife yeah you know she
says to me you cheated on me he says
right you know and i take responsibility
for that but really isn't about all of
us isn't it about the bigger picture
here here's jake sullivan doing this
pathetic routine
he's taking responsibility for every
decision the united states government
took with respect to afghanistan because
as he said the buck stops with him
i am also taking responsibility and so
are my colleagues the secretary of state
the secretary of defense the chairman
and the joint chiefs of staff the
directors of our intelligence agencies
we as a national security team
collectively take responsibility for
every decision good
decision
every decision that doesn't produce
perfect outcomes that is what
responsibility is now at the same time
that doesn't change the fact that there
are other parties here responsible as
well oh
we take total responsibility for all of
our decisions also it's them
by the way speaking of uh people who are
doing excellent reporting clarissa ward
over at cnn has been getting some flack
for no reason it seems to me for her
reporting on the ground she's now having
don a burka in order to continue
reporting over there she's got the hijab
on she doesn't have the full face
covering on because she's in front of
the camera um but uh if you want to see
what has happened in afghanistan all you
have to do is check her garb from a week
ago versus her garb now and that of
course is no fault of her own she's
doing excellent reporting she's
reporting that over at kabul airport
quote this is mayhem this is nuts it is
impossible for an ordinary civilian even
if they have their paperwork to get out
no way they are running that gauntlet no
way they're going to be able to navigate
that there's no order there's no
coherent system evacuation which was
supposed to be the chief priority here
right making sure everybody gets out uh
they're not
according to the biden administration on
tuesday this is the wall street journal
reporting the airport in kabul was open
for both military and civilian flights
but access remains near impossible for
the thousands of afghans seeking to
leave afghanistan as the taliban
strengthened control over the city and a
taliban leader returned from exile
military flights resumed as the us sends
additional troops to secure the
perimeter and manage air traffic control
and ground operations following two days
of chaos while westerners and afghans
raced to escape the country the u.s said
it had completed the evacuation of its
embassy staff leaving only a small
contingent to process other departures
from the country by the way the usmc
embassy staff should if this were an
orderly transition be the last people to
leave right they have to be there on the
ground to process the paperwork they
were the first people to leave because
this pla this is just a show i mean it's
just it is a bleep show however many
thousands of afghans who had worked for
western embassies and organizations
remained stranded and unable to reach
the airport for evacuation flights the
taliban erected checkpoints at the
entrances of the airport they're
whipping and beating afghans who attempt
it to cross even with their paperwork
plus by the way there's no guarantee
that americans who are there are going
to be able to get out at this point
so the nsa jake sullivan again this is
one of the most catastrophic press
conferences i've ever personally
witnessed and that means really really
bad jake sullivan was asked are we going
to um have troops there past august 31st
to facilitate the exit of both americans
who are stuck in afghanistan and afghan
allies were stuck in afghanistan and
jake sullivan wouldn't commit to that by
the way the date as of right now is
august 18th
so you're saying we may not have troops
past 13 days out from now to help people
get out
here we
go will u.s troops stay until everyone
is out or will they leave so i'm not
going to comment on hypotheticals what
i'm going to do is stay focused on the
task at hand which is getting as many
people out as rapidly as possible and we
will take that day by day you can't
commit to bringing back every american
and then he was asked can you guarantee
every american is going to get out and
he really didn't have any answer for
that then he was asked you know
why exactly didn't we get these people
out earlier we had we were there for 20
years why didn't we facilitate their
exit earlier and sullivan has no answer
there have been questions raised about
whether we should have drawn down our
embassy and evacuated our afghan allies
earlier
these are reasonable questions we did
dramatically accelerate the siv process
and move out a substantial number of siv
applicants and their families
but the afghan government and its
supporters
including many of the people now seeking
to leave made a passionate case that we
should not conduct a mass evacuation
lest we trigger a loss of confidence in
the government
amazing amazing we shouldn't i mean like
the the excuse making here so the reason
that we didn't evacuate earlier is
because we were told by the afghan
government which no longer exists that
if we evacuated earlier then it might
undercut their credibility
wait a second wasn't the president of
the united states one month ago saying
that the afghan government would not
capitulate that kabul would not fall
this was not going to be like saigon we
were told that a month ago so maybe it
was actually your boss jake sullivan and
you who were doing this who are making
sure that nobody got out by the way jen
saki was was asked can you guarantee
that americans are all going to make it
out that everybody's going to get out
and she uh she mush-mouthed it
can you
offer any guarantee to the americans and
afghan allies that if they remain there
past the end of the month u.s troops
will help them evacuate we'll pass the
end of the month
our our focus right now is undoing the
work at hand and on the task at hand and
that is day by day getting as many
american citizens as many siv applicants
as many members of a vulnerable
population who are eligible to be
evacuated to the airport and out on
planes and we're going to do that in
expeditious fashion that is the focus of
the president of our secretary of
defense of our secretary of state and
everybody on our national security team
uh so that that is where we will keep
our efforts
you know they're keeping their focus on
making sure that everybody gets out but
they're not guaranteeing that
everybody's going to get out it's kind
of awkward you know sort of as though
they've kept their focus on the border
but they've done nothing over there in a
second we're going to see the actual
plan for getting people out it is
unbelievable okay we'll get to the
actual plan for getting people out um a
lot of people can get out okay
particularly our afghan allies they're
screwed they're absolutely screwed i'm
getting letters from soldiers every hour
talking about people they worked with
are just going to get murdered over
there we'll get to this in just one
second first it can be overwhelming to
perform at your best as you age career
family staying in shape life can get
stressful you start to slow down you're
not present when you want to be to
perform at your best physically and
mentally you can't let age beat you this
is where m drive can help m drive is the
daily supplement for driven men who
don't want to slow down who refuse to be
tired every day and want to be the best
at what they do it is packed with
clinically tested ingredients that
support healthy testosterone levels
while helping you lose weight and stay
lean add vitamins and nutrients reduce
stress boost your drive so you can
perform at your best find it at
walgreens and other retailers or visit
mdrive4men.com get 20 off your first
order with promo code ben they got free
shipping they have a 60-day money-back
guarantee so you have nothing to lose m
drive it's not for everyone it's for the
driven go check them out right now m
drive4men.com promo code ben again that
is the letter m
drive4men.com promo code ben give it a
try see if it boosts your energy level i
think it will they've got free shipping
a 60-day money-back guarantee so again
there really is no risk to this thing
increase your drive with mdrive4men.com
use promo code ben when you get 20 off
your very first order when you use that
promo code ben alrighty so what is the
actual plan for getting people out the
actual plan is well trust the taliban i
kid you not this is the plan according
to the uk daily mail the white house
confirmed it is relying on the taliban
to help provide safe passage for
civilians looking to evacuate
afghanistan as the state department
warns u.s civilians there to shelter in
place until it is safe to leave here is
jake sullivan explaining guys taliban is
not going to stop people who are trying
to get to the airport like americans why
would they do that
can you tell us what is it exactly the
commitment that you have secured from
the taliban regarding the safe passage
of americans as well as as the tens of
thousands of vulnerable afghans the
taliban have informed us that they are
prepared to provide the safe passage of
civilians to the airport and we intend
to hold them to that commitment
oh they do you you're gonna hold them to
that commitment or what
or what this should always be the
question that comes to this
administration now or what
what are you gonna do yell at them send
them a vaguely worded letter
you want to do something military
related yeah i'm sure i'm sure after you
pulled out and after you said screw all
the people who are there i'm sure that
they they're quaking in their boots with
the notion
that that this balding road scholar is
going to somehow threaten them into
submission if things go wrong yes
clearly that this dottering old
president is going to unleash the gates
of hell upon these people if they don't
allow americans out or alternatively
we're going to beg them and we're going
gonna plead with them and then if they
don't do what they said they would do
then you know we'll just kind of like
take it
well you know that that's what we're
gonna do by the way it is six weeks
since joe biden was specifically asked
about trusting the taliban he said no i
do not trust the taliban now we are
trusting the taliban to allow all the
americans out
sullivan says by and large what we have
found is that people who have been able
to get to the airport and present
themselves there have been instances you
know where we've heard that people are
being turned back and even beaten we're
taking that up in our channels with the
taliban oh well then i'm sure things are
going fine i'm sure that that is just
going great pentagon spokesperson john
kirby was asked okay so are you actually
like sending people out to gather the
americans are you sending people out
from the military to go into kabul and
pick people up and bring them back to
the airport and here is his idiotic
response
we're working hand in glove with the
state department uh in terms of
supporting their plans at processing
these individuals uh but again that's
something that we're going to be doing
on a case-by-case day by day basis right
now though i don't want to set the
expectation that
that we are equipped and and able to go
out into the countryside and physically
move people into kabul our focus right
now the troops that we have there are at
the airport the idea is to make sure we
can get that the air operations not only
have they resumed but to keep them in
place for as long as possible
oh okay well then it's all fine kirby
was also asked about our afghan allies
and whether they can get out he's like
well you know we're gonna have to check
their paperwork and clarissa ward of cnn
was having none of it again she's been
doing excellent work here i don't know
why people are giving her flack
i'm the one who has to look them in the
eye can i offer them your assurance that
everyone who has worked with american
organizations
will be got out of this country safely
clarissa first of all thanks for uh your
incredibly brave reporting uh and the uh
and the images and the stories that
you're telling uh we're all grateful and
we all know how hard and how dangerous
that work is i would ask you to tell
them that there is a process uh that
that they can apply for through the
state department to to get onto the list
and get on to the manifest and i would
ask them to to work with
state department authorities there in
kabul to do that and if they if they are
through that process i can assure them
and you can assure them on our behalf
that we in the pentagon will do
everything we can to help get them out
of the country over the next couple of
weeks that's what we're flowing in extra
aircraft for that's why we're flowing in
extra troops to maintain security at
that airport so that we can do that
you'll notice that what he is saying
there provides no guarantee that people
who should be able to get out of the
country get out of the country you know
they should file their paperwork and
then they should wait they should wait
around shelter in place wait around
while the taliban threaten murder them
and then you know maybe after we file
their paperwork we'll find a way to get
them out of the country these are people
who put their lives on the lines on
behalf of american interests by the way
and as i say i've been getting dozens of
letters from soldiers like every day
saying i worked with this family in
afghanistan i can't get in touch with
them please can you do something me okay
i'm a political commentator i'm not a
member of the government i'm not a
member of the state department i'm not
i'm not an elected official i'm getting
letters like this
okay that's how horrible this
administration is at doing what it said
it would do
meanwhile the administration patting
itself on the back jake sullivan says
you know all of this just proves that we
should have left
oh
really that's interesting so i think the
argument could then be made
that the rise in crime rates in
america's major cities in the aftermath
of the police pulling back is just
evidence i mean if people don't
obviously people there want crime defund
the police is probably a good idea then
right if you take away the people who
are the protective force and then bad
things happen this just proves that
people wanted bad things to happen so
you shouldn't have had a protective
force there in the first place this is
so counterintuitive and nonsensical
what has unfolded over the past month
has proven decisively that it would have
taken a significant american true
presence multiple times greater than
what president biden was handed to stop
a taliban onslaught
and we would have taken casualties
american men and women would have been
fighting and dying once again in
afghanistan and president biden was not
prepared to send additional forces or
ask any american personnel to do that
over the period ahead
um no so that is um no that is not
actually what was happening there was a
skeleton force there none of this was
happening skeleton force is gone all of
this is happening it's that simple
okay meanwhile i have to say it is
astonishing to watch it
my mind is boggled at not only the lack
of competence but the lack of
even basic decency and honesty from this
administration it really is an amazing
thing all the people like trump violated
all norms trump was the worst trump mean
tweet
okay now i've noticed that um 38 million
people are now living under abject
tyranny over there and also all of our
enemies are on the move globally all of
them but don't worry jake sullivan says
that our allies should actually feel
comforted by all of this
if you're taiwan now under threat from
china
if you are israel under threat from
hamas then you should feel comforted by
america's commitment here because it's
not like we just cut and run and left a
giant country a strategically important
country that borders both india and
pakistan and also iran it's not like we
just left that country in the hands of
literally the worst people on the planet
who were responsible for the destruction
of the twin towers in 2001 and the
pentagon in 2001 in the murder of three
thousand americans in 2000 it's not like
we just did any of that all of our
allies should feel super confident given
the fact that we are now going to leave
our allies in afghanistan to be abjectly
murdered i mean just shot in the streets
they our allies should feel pretty
comfortable says jake sullivan
we believe that our commitments to our
allies and partners are sacrosanct and
always have been we believe our
commitment to
taiwan and to israel remains as strong
as it's ever been keep in mind that with
respect to afghanistan we said back in
2011 that we would be out in 2014
we stayed another seven years
oh well yeah i mean they should feel
they i'm sure our allies will feel very
comfortable they're so comfortable in
fact that all of our enemies are on the
move according to reuters iran has now
accelerated its enrichment of uranium to
your weapons grade a move raising
tensions with the west as both sides
seek to resume talks on reviving
tehran's nuclear deal
who could have predicted this you mean
iran is ramping up because they know
that they can now take this
administration for all their worth so
iran is ramping up you'll see iran ramp
up its terror activities in yemen in
syria in lebanon
because why the hell wouldn't they this
is a weak pathetic muelling
administration china meanwhile held an
assault drill near taiwan after
so-called provocations according to
reuters china carried out assault drills
near taiwan on tuesday with warships and
fighter jets exercising off the
southwest and southeast of the island
and what the country's armed forces said
was a response to quote external
interference and provocations and so
they are now looking at the possibility
of military action against taiwan
they've already threatened and said well
you know the truth is that the united
states ain't going to do anything so
maybe you should work with us
meanwhile the state department had no
answer on why exactly the the biden
administration was so sanguine about
chinese prospects in afghanistan
remember the the state department said
just this week they said you know china
and russia they're probably pretty upset
we pulled out from afghanistan the thing
they wanted most was for us to stay
weird says andrea mitchell again
shockingly doing an act of journalism
here saying i've noticed that the china
are happy to work with the taliban
china is moving towards recognition of
the taliban already
well i look without any guarantees of
human rights or any other guarantees uh
it just so happens that
china the people's republic of china is
a permanent member of the u.s security
council uh so i can tell you precisely
uh what they said
uh when
uh they signed on to the statement on
august 16th but what they're doing today
is moving towards recognizing the
taliban
i am going to have to defer to officials
in beijing to speak to what they're
doing i can tell you precisely what they
signed on to precisely
what tell you about their intent
i i'm not here to divine the intent of
the prc government
my god i mean their attendance is
perfectly clear we know exactly what
they're doing we know exactly so this
meant oh my god they're just such liars
they're such unbelievable liars
meanwhile this administration let's
recognize
as far as our allies go right so if
you're an ally of the united states you
have to feel super uncomfortable at this
point like why wouldn't you engage in
the real politic of attempting to
triangulate by by playing off the united
states against for example china and
russia why wouldn't you be attempting to
reach out to other great powers for some
semblance of support why wouldn't you
become more of a free agent see the
united states in order to have allies
has to make commitments and it has to
fulfill those commitments we have so far
this decade abandoned the kurds
abandoned the people of hong kong
abandoned the dissidents in iran
abandoned the dissidents in cuba
abandoned the entire country of
afghanistan we are about to abandon our
allies in taiwan so what exactly is the
incentive for anyone to make a sacrifice
in order to be an ally to the united
states what is the incentive the answer
is there is no incentive and remember
this is the same administration that is
currently attempting to for example
legitimize in large measure israel's
opponents right so if you're israel do
you trust the united if you're saudi if
you're the saudis do you trust the
united states at this point to have your
back if things get hairy
why would you
by the way hamas which has been which
was treated by the entire media not as
the provocateur and terrorist group that
it is in the last israel hamas conflict
but instead as a sort of victimized
power
hamas is celebrating the taliban
takeover they issued a statement
welcoming quote the defeat of the
american occupation in all afghan land
and praising the taliban's courageous
leadership on this victory which was the
culmination of its long struggle over
the past 20 years definitely people that
we should force israel into negotiations
with
meanwhile by the way there seems to be
this idea out there by the biden
administration that all this is going to
make maiden more popular that in the end
pulling out from afghanistan is going to
create vast popularity here's the thing
the american people are congenitally
isolationist
americans are not particularly fond of
presidents who campaign on the basis of
going into war going all the way back to
world war one when woodrow wilson
literally campaigned in 1916 on the
slogan he kept us out of the war and
then proceeded to take us into world war
one so americans are really not fond of
war we don't want to be in wars but
there is one thing that americans hate
worse than getting in war and that's
getting our ass kicked by a bunch of
savage barbarians from the 8th century
we are not fond of that look
particularly and joe biden is feeling
that in the approval ratings we'll get
to that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact you don't want to go
to an auto parts store why would you i
mean really you wait in line you finally
get up to the front you got a beta or
work look-alike going hey bro
what kind of part do you need then you
orders it online he up charges you it
takes you 25 minutes and then finally
the part comes three weeks later you
have to go back to the auto parts store
or you could just go to the interwebs
the greatest of all places rockauto.com
it's so much easier than walking into
the store and going through that entire
silly process instead rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do why would you spend up to twice as
much for the same parts their family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the catalog is
unique it's remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands specifications and prices you
prefer go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck rich shapiro in their how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you again head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
write shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you already we'll get some more of the
news in just one moment first you
deserve to wake up to the facts which is
why we started our newest podcast
morning wire it's been topping the apple
and spotify charts since its recent
release i'm very proud of this product
you should check it out it's the only
daily news podcast that values your time
and the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending toward number one
subscribe start listening now to morning
wire on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear also we
have a special deal for you right now
if you sign up as a daily wire member
with code vip not only did you get 25
off your new membership you also will be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip for two right this is an
amazing deal a trip for two you and a
guest to the daily wire studios to see
candace owens live not only will you
meet candace but get an inside look at
her studio front row seats to watch her
takedown left us live in action on her
talk show candace hurry because this
deal ends today so you're getting a
couple of things number one you get 25
off the daily membership which is the
best deal available dailywire.com
subscribe use code vip but then you also
are automatically entered for a chance
to win a magical romantic honeymoon trip
to two four two to come to the daily
wire offices and hang out with candace
at the candace owens show this deal ends
today act fast that's dailywear.com
subscribe get 25 off with code vip you
are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
hey so many of the folks in the media
they keep pretending that at some point
at some point biden is going to emerge
unscathed from all this which is what
they really care about because here is
the deal we are now decline is a choice
it is a phrase that the charles
krauthammer once used in a speech he
gave a very very famous speech in 2009
when he said decline is a choice you
know people act as though the decline of
the united states is inevitable but you
actually have to make the active choice
for decline joe biden has chosen a
decline he has chosen the bloated
cancerous social democracy ideas of
europe for home and he has chosen the
surrender first caucus politics abroad
we are in we are a country and a
republic in decline and that decline is
in fact a choice we are not muscular in
our own defense we are not interested in
our own interests we have decided we are
going to blow out the debt at home we
are going to spend more money than god
or man has ever seen or created and we
are going to destroy our own credibility
on the world stage and hand it over to
our enemies at the same time
we are watching the self-cannibalization
of the american legacy in real time but
the media are convinced that all this is
fine for joe biden because if joe biden
doesn't spend the money on guns over
there he can spend the money on butter
here at home is the idea so nicole
wallace is leading this ridiculous group
of folks over at msnbc she says you know
what 95 of americans agree with biden
really nicole do they
95 of the american people will agree
with everything he just said
95 of the press covering this white
house will disagree
and for an american president
to finally be completely aligned with
such an overwhelming majority of what
the american people think about
afghanistan is probably a tremendous
relief to the american people
okay so this is what the media are going
to turn to so again i'm not going to say
the whole media because there are some
who are honest enough to note what is
happening here but the nicole wallace
party line here which is that eventually
the american people are going to turn in
favor of all this and be super happy
about it i have serious doubts right now
the polls show that joe biden has
dropped below 50 for the first time in
his entire presidency uh he is well
below 50 percent actually his
disapproval which started at 35 in
february is now up to 46.1
it turns out the american people are not
fans of failure joe biden is an abject
failure how much of a failure is joe
biden according to jake sullivan that
national security adviser joe biden in
the process of this entire debacle has
not spoken to a single foreign leader
remember this is this is the great
diplomacy first president this is the
man who said on national tv just two
days ago he was pursuing diplomacy ties
with our international allies he has
been in camp david
playing
old atari games and watching matlock
while eating ensure with a spoon
well not calling any of our allies
according to jake sullivan
he has not yet spoken with any other
world leaders uh
myself secretary blinken several other
senior members of the team have been
engaged on a regular basis with foreign
counterparts
and we intend to do so in the coming
days right now the main issue is an
operational issue it's about how we
coordinate with them to help them get
their people out
we've not spoken any foreign leaders hey
by the way jen saki was asked so when
does biden return to dc she was asked
this yesterday he said well there's
really no timetable because remember he
did his little press conference and then
he just walked out and headed right back
to vacation
the president will return
to the white house i don't have an exact
time for you but tomorrow he will uh
both be
doing an interview with george
stephanopoulos for abc and he will also
where he will of course i'm certain be
speaking to the situation on the ground
in afghanistan he'll also be delivering
some remarks on kovid as well in terms
of additional
portions of the schedule next week we're
still working those through so i don't
have an update for you at this moment in
time
um so
there is an update joe biden is headed
back to the white house today he is
going to speak about kovid
because very important to misdirect away
from the complete surrender and abject
humiliation of the united states and
afghanistan so he's going to talk more
about covet he's going to yell at ron
desantis i would assume well by the way
quick note on that the trajectory for
the delta variants in florida and hawaii
they're identical i was just in hawaii
hawaii is totally masked hawaii has a
full regimen you have to in order to get
into hawaii you have to show that you've
been vaccinated or you have to show a
negative pcr test within the last 48
hours
and hawaii has the exact same trajectory
as florida so it turns out the delta
variant is extremely transmissible
people are getting it it ain't about
desantis but biden needs some talking
points to get people to stop talking
about the fact that he's an incompetent
buffoon even chuck todd who's normally
administration cheerleader he says uh
yeah the veneer of confidence that's
gone
i do think the biggest political fallout
from this is competency
joe biden's greatest strength against
donald trump in the campaign was the
idea that he's been around the block he
knows what he's doing we're facing this
crisis with covid we need some basic
competency back in government no more
chaos
he's lost the competency uh uh high
marks that he was getting at one time
that's tough to get back
um so yeah that is um
it's not coming back nobody thinks he's
competent
the only question for democrats is
whether they think the people around him
are competent this is the question for a
lot of people on the republican side
when trump was president there are a lot
of people who are like trump is
incompetent and a lot of us would say
okay well whatever trump is tweeting
today the people around him are actually
really competent look at the policy i
look at the policy don't look at the
tweets look at the policy forget about
the mean tweets for a second look at
what he's actually doing he had record
prosperity we had stability on the
foreign on the foreign front we were
facing up to the problem of china we're
facing up to the problem of russia we
were cutting peace deals in the middle
east forget about trump personally okay
well democrats don't have the ability to
do this because the people around biden
are also promoting this idiotic policy
right biden
is not there he's not been there for
quite a while the lights are on but
nobody is home
that attic is missing a couple of boxes
and the people around him are doing
nothing to facilitate actual competency
in government
representative seth moulton democrat
from massachusetts who actually is a
former military member even he was
ripping on the president of the united
states yesterday on msnbc
with the number of people we need to get
out and the number of days that we had
before u.s troop withdrawal is complete
they should have been conducting this
evacuation for months
this is the first question i asked
secretary austin when he came before the
house armed services committee just two
months ago i said mr secretary why have
you not already begun this evacuation
all the scenes of total chaos that we
saw play out on the tv yesterday could
have been avoided if the administration
had planned for this in advance
correct
full disclosure i know representative
molten on this sort of stuff he's
terrific okay he is correct on this this
is a this is
it's it's an act of pure insanity what
has happened here by the way how
delusional does the united states remain
so ambassador linda thomas greenfield
was asked on cnn by wolf blitzer about
the taliban violating people's rights
her answer was in no uncertain terms the
united nations would be putting through
quote a very strongly worded press
statement from the security council that
we expect the taliban to respect women's
rights and to be respectful of
humanitarian law well i mean guess
case closed we're done here the bite
administration and our allies our allies
hmm on the u.n security council like
china and russia definitely that yeah
that's strongly worded statements
to a bunch of eighth century barbarians
who are literally wielding whips i kid
you not is according to cnn reporter
clarissa ward they're wielding whips at
the airport to smack any afghan
attempting to leave the country and
escape their barbaric rule
if we issue a strongly a very strongly
worded statement says ambassador linda
thomas greenfield at the un if we do
that definitely they will stop doing
what they have been doing
because after all they're not 8th
century barbarians we just handed
billions of dollars in sophisticated
military hardware
and an entire country
it'll be fine guys it'll be fine the
competence is here the adults are back
in charge how refreshing remember we
were told all this in january oh the
adults are back isn't it nice to have
competent governance again isn't it nice
weird because that went when that
terrible incompetent orange man was
there none of this bleep was happening
remember that
yeah all you guys were doing was whining
about how how he was tweeting and
and now we've got this
now we've got this
okay but here's the thing many on the
left are satisfied with this because
in the end their agenda is not about
american security their agenda is not
about strengthening the united states
for many on the left they're happy that
we are redirecting all of our focus from
enemies abroad to enemies within this is
a serious serious problem
there are a lot of people on the left
who are far more concerned with the
enemies within than with the enemies
abroad this is why you saw the spectacle
of general mark milley of the joint
chiefs of staff
saying to congress that he was deeply
deeply concerned about the roots of
white rage he had to have his soldiers
laura they had to read about max kennedy
to learn about critical race theory and
the roots of white rage we definitely
needed that
we needed lloyd austin the secretary of
defense
talking about how we needed to diversify
the military this was a key priority the
walkification of the military this was
this was key not actually winning wars
by the way who's gonna get fired for
this anybody
bueller no one's gonna get fired for
this
if you're this incompetent at your job
you'd be fired forthwith like within
seconds
these these
jackasses have made a mockery like an
absolute mockery of the sacrifices of
the brave men and women of the american
armed services who sacrificed in many
cases in thousands of cases their lives
in tens of thousands of cases their body
parts their livelihoods their mental
health in order to establish american
security on the ground in afghanistan
and provide us a base to fight terrorism
from and yes to add to the humanitarian
values that were in afghanistan
right those people have been abjectly
betrayed by this administration i'm
getting letters from them all day long
the last several days
and this administration they they were
focusing on what really mattered and
that was the threat of white supremacy
within that was the threat of domestic
terrorism in the united states
okay so
the there are bad people in the united
states they exist but the
incredible
conflation like the left knows what's
happening here they do they're hard left
to understand that what they've just
done is humiliate themselves globally
like really humiliate themselves that's
what this represents and so they have to
come up with an alternative narrative
and the alternative narrative is that
the taliban
yeah they're bad but we've got bad
people here too
the taliban are really bad
but you know what we have an american
taliban we need to fight we need to
bring those soldiers home not to as so
many on the right seem to think send
them to the border
or redeploy them to the south china sea
no the left would like to bring
everybody home focus all of our
resources internally and this is also
true with our moral capital it used to
be the united states exported its moral
capital right we had all this moral
capital we were the most
free country most powerful country in
the history of the world in the history
of the world the most tolerant and
diverse country in the history of the
world by the way also
and we were exporting that moral capital
abroad
sometimes to great effects sometimes to
no effect and sometimes to help build
nascent democracy in places like iraq
and yes at the beginning in afghanistan
or
maybe we were doing it unsuccessfully in
afghanistan but successfully in germany
and japan right the united states has a
long history of exporting our moral
capital elsewhere
but now because the left has decided we
have no moral capital instead we have to
take all of our reasons we have to we
have to stop interfering in world
affairs we have to let our enemies take
advantage of the vacuum that we create
we have to focus all of our moral
resources at home we have to rebuild our
moral capital and rebuilding that moral
capital starts at home we have to make
sure that all of our public school
students learn about their white
privilege we have to ensure that america
sees its dire history of racism sexism
bigotry and homophobia we have to
rebuild morally speaking and that means
taking on the real enemy the real enemy
is not tens of thousands of miles away
the real enemy is not in afghanistan the
real enemy is not terrorists or china
the real enemy is here within that's the
enemy that we have to fight according to
members of the hard left so you have the
specter of stephen colbert is
unbelievable likening trump voters to
the taliban this happened two nights ago
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
he's right
we've had troops there for 20 years
they fought
they sacrificed their families
sacrificed so that we wouldn't have a
terrorist attack
in america planned in a foreign country
why should our soldiers be fighting
radicals in a civil war in afghanistan
we've got our own on capitol hill
we've got our own on capitol hill you
see the people who are outside the
capitol that was what that picture was
the people who are outside the capitol
building on january 6th they are the
same as the american taliban they're the
they are just the same thing they're the
same
oh are they now
fascinating so if that were the case and
and by the way that's that's what he
wants right the idea is that we have to
redeploy the american military against
people who disagree with with stephen
colbert that's that's
that's an unbelievable statement right
there okay so by the way even in that
statement he acknowledges why we were
supposed to remain in afghanistan to
fight terrorism because guess what that
threat has not ended and now it's going
to be reconstituted in afghanistan but
that's a side point for the radical left
the enemy is not the taliban those are
people who are very far away engaged in
a civil war the enemy is you the enemy
is people who think like you who
disagree with stephen colbert he doesn't
mean that we need the american military
there to put down
actual violent action only at the
capitol building
no far from it the left conflates all
those people you see the left is not
interested in separating off the people
who engaged in violent activity and who
were duly arrested at the capitol
building
the left believes that everyone who is
outside the capital is the same as
everybody who actually violated the law
they believe that everybody who voted
for donald trump is the same as the
people outside the capitol this is what
the left does
we have violent terrorists in the united
by the way you know what happened with
their you know how many people were
actually murdered on that day
and the answer is that no actual people
were murdered on that day the only
person who was actually killed on that
day as in actively killed on that day
was ashley babbitt who was one of the
protesters one of the rioters right she
was engaging in criminal activity
that's the and the entire place was
cleared within three hours and the uh
and the government went on so if that
sounds a lot like the taliban it's
because you're a crazy person it's
because you're out of your damned mind
there's also
there are also gradations of people
doing bad things and believing terrible
things okay the people who invaded the
capitol building and the belief that the
election was illegitimate are not
remotely on the level of human beings in
afghanistan who wish to crowd women back
into basements keep them there as sex
slaves for decades on end make sure they
can't go to school make sure that
everybody lives under the most brutal
and violent form of sharia law
like can we make any sort of gradations
here can we say that even if we think
that the january 6th riots were an act
of evil that that is a different level
of evil than people who are literally
living in stone age barbarism and
murdering people in order to ensure that
stone age barbarism rules
are there no gradations here at all
according to the left there aren't and
in fact the people in the united states
who did this are much more dangerous to
us than the taliban
they're much more like because 911 never
happened you say 9 11 was a figment of
your imagination
9 11
in fact what happened on january 6th is
worse than 9 11 in the minds of the left
because it came from here even though it
resulted again
in no murders
that that that is not to downplay the
evil of that but but to the comparison
to 911 itself is idiotic but to the left
it's worse it's worse than 911. 911
basically never happened according to
the left so we don't have to worry about
threats abroad anymore those are done
according to stephen colbert the real
threat is you the real threat is people
who think like you
and by the way if you don't think that
they are conflating everybody if you
think that colbert is just talking about
the writers you're wrong malcolm nance
who you'll recall i debated on on bill
maher and i pointed out that malcolm
nance has a really really nasty habit of
conflating the people who engaged in
criminal activity on january 6th with
everyone who voted for trump now malcolm
nance has a new theory his theory is
that trump voters everywhere are going
to engage in an actual violent civil war
which would explain why we need to pull
out from afghanistan to activate against
those people here's malcolm nance doing
what he does most often which is claim
that he has inside intelligence
information suggesting that a massive
civil war is about to break out in the
united states led by trump
these guys view themselves as this
fanciful group of patriotic freedom
fighters the second
coming of the sons of liberty and there
are many of them who are preparing for
civil war right now all the shame that
we tried to give them after january 6
that's gone there are many of them right
now that are ready to fight and we're
seeing politicians in the state houses
and the capital who are actually you
know pushing them subliminally to fight
this doltish claude here's what he had
to say right before that quote the
republican party is more like shin fine
and the relationship between shin fine
the irish nationalist party and the
irish republican army provisional irish
republican army terrorist group who
called themselves freedom fighters and
insurgents and had americans american
congressmen sending them money to buy
you know heavy machine guns
okay so
the idea here again from the left
increasingly is that the taliban
are not bad right or at least they're
not really a threat maybe they're not
great but really should we worry about
them the real threat is everyone who
voted republican everyone who voted
trump those people are the real threat
those are the people we deeply have to
worry about michael moore made this
absolutely clear so michael moore is a
is a complete buffoon he tweeted out
their taliban are taliban everybody's
got a taliban they're at their best when
they confiscate the hulls of power and
then he tweeted a picture of the taliban
sitting at the uh seat of the national
government and then the uh buffoonish
idiots who invaded the capitol building
on january 6th
um
you will know that the people
in the upper picture the taliban
they're going to murder probably tens of
thousands of human beings
they are also going to
retain this dictatorship until
presumably the end of time
and uh the people at the bottom are a
bunch of clods
in buffalo hats
who were cleared out of the capital and
arrested within three hours
those are not comparable
those are not remotely comparable
but if you can draw the parallel the
left has been doing this for for 20
years by the way but but now it's really
kicked into high gear since trump
if you can draw the parallel between
enemies abroad and enemies at home you
can treat enemies at home as we treated
enemies abroad this is dangerous stuff
this is dangerous stuff
because for members of the radical left
and increasingly the mainstream left if
the idea is we rebuild moral capital by
destroying the enemies here at home this
is how tyranny happens is how
authoritarianism happens if you are
justified in freedom i mean after all we
literally fought the taliban
we unleash the drones on them we've
probably killed tens of thousands of
members of the taliban over the years
if
if there's an equivalent group in the
united states to the taliban we would
have to treat them like we treated the
taliban would we not
members of the left are eager and happy
about that of the hard left
if that sentiment grows that really is a
threat to the future of the country on a
broad scale but we have many threats to
the future of the country we have the
radicals on the left who think that
everybody who disagrees with them is the
american taliban it must be thoroughly
destroyed
we have a group of people on the left
who believe that government ought to
rule all of our lives on the basis of
the slim the slimmest and thinnest of
reeds like at this point the covid
pandemic
we have people on the left who believe
that the pathway back to american moral
capital is to completely destroy the
american economic system by burdening it
with the greatest spending binge in the
history of of anything and to destroy
america's credibility on the foreign
stage
decline is a choice the left is choosing
it alrighty we'll be back here later
today with for an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out the
michael knowles show on today's episode
michael will be talking about lizzo's
complaints over fat phobia that episode
is available right now i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
the biden administration refuses to
guarantee the safety of americans
stranded in afghanistan the ruling class
demands we take in millions of refugees
and new zealand locks down over a single
covet case check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]